lockyer into this video around eight of
the candidates tournament and we have a
game here to analyze between T'Pol off
and Mammadyarov both the players lost
terribly around seven and for both that
basically meant the end of the any
ambition for the first place I mean like
almost there on minus one but
theoretically speaking there is some
some hope left but it's very very little
especially Mammadyarov had chronic on
the ropes and could have been right in
the middle in the thick of it but he
blundered in this super complicated
position and even lost so let's see what
happened in this game we have an open
Sicilian and I'm wondering is this the
first open Sicilian in this in this
tournament they have been Bishop b5
check things I'm trying to remember I'm
not sure are we had to attend the first
dance will I had played the time enough
and they actually had an open source in
kayaking white okay I just remember okay
here we get an ID off and what is to
pollow's preparation against the night
of interesting he very often goes for
the sharpest lines with Bishop to d3 or
Bishop g5 materia is coming up with the
different movement with age three yeah
this is an 08 favorites of bobby
fischer's and despite its somewhat
slower and harmless appearance this is
actually a quite sharp move their ideas
very straightforward to play g4 yeah
well in the let's say in the ravening on
there is the carers attack where you can
play g4 immediately here of course g4 is
just oozing upon so why does preparing
this advanced and g4 is very often just
intending g5 pushing this night away and
this is also a motivation for
this move to prepare but the h3 is a bit
different and we'll see one idea later
mama Jonathan o goes for g6 which is a
slightly rare move and most people here
go for e six and after that we get a
position that very often arises from the
keris attack especially if black goes
goes h6 okay but g6 was played yeah g4s
mentioned this is the idea why does
going for this extended fianchetto and
note he hasn't cashed lot yet so we look
at this yeah T'Pol off he's preparing
long castling and why not I mean why it
has a very nice control of the center
the bishop on d2.is can put this on the
bot the bishop on d 2 is supporting
control over d5 so black is not going to
play d5 anytime soon and white has ideas
to further expand like f 4g 5 or
breaking through with f4 and d5 if the
concrete circumstances permit such
action yeah what is the drawback of
whites position yeah one drawback is
compared to the normal dragon and this
is essentially a dragon now black black
summation is typical drag information um
yeah one drawback is that the square c4
is not controlled we see that after Luke
c 8f for Knight a5 leg is aiming to go
to the square so this is a big
difference to the regular dragon wear
white has the bishop only have one still
on b3 this is even more often the case
and there and night on c4 can always
just be taken by this piece which is not
possible here I just wanted to quickly
mention that instead of rook c8 like
also has the very sharp move beef
available which was played by the magnus
carlsen our current world champion this
is actually an interesting move and very
sharp one note that white cannot go e
five here as this year leads to a
fantastic compensation with night c4 and
before coming a very nice position from
like before would have been a very
interesting sharp alternative and an
idea is also that black is of course
quickly trying to play v5b form in the
in the game domingues Carlson it went
like that and this is a complete mess
black seems to be quite okay though yeah
mama dro played rook c8 he just went out
of this long diagonal which is not a bad
choice not a five year i just mentioned
night see form assumes that like will
definitely play if not hindered and
white absolutely must play be three this
is what the pile of dead you cannot
allow the night there it's simply the
only play will move be three of course
it's a move that you only make with some
reluctance because it we can so see file
this night has now not grounded anymore
protected by the pond and there are some
weaknesses yelled at c2 c3 now I'm not
saying why it has a problem it's just
like very important for the further
cause of the game yeah Queen c7 plate
okay the C file is clear as your source
of plate and two part of retreated the
night there is no no real choice here I
mean you can try 95 but it looks a bit
bit shaky to do that right now this is a
good idea it also permits this this move
and did might threaten a five and g5
what I mean what I'm trying to say is
that this type of
thing is to be considered b5 was played
this was a possibility to pile of played
95 but this is something that you must
consider is this good for what at first
it looks excellent this night is a
checked and if it moves okay I'm going
to take your bishop but Jack has a good
reply it's not that move still winning a
piece but black actually has this move
it's just very strong it protects the d7
bishop and after the capture black can
move this piece yep and ask white okay
where are you going with your queen
actually yeah i'm at the end something
like that leads to a really messy play
but black seems to be okay g5 if I've
ng5 is a bit a bit too much to pull off
plate 95 is mentioned there what else is
there the computer actually recommends
King to be one which I actually do like
very much the thing is yeah what does
blacks moves now it's not so clear what
he what he will play um White's idea is
to play 95 anyway yeah and this is what
the polyp did instantly and this move
was just saying to like okay I just make
a move and do something it's not so easy
to to play a useful move here you can
yeah you can try rook e8 for example but
then g5 person is an idea the night he
does not have a good square something
like that you actually cannot play at
all
we can go for complete embarrassment
ruki 8 is simply not not a good move
yeah maybe before something that black
should play at the end and after 95
takes takes we get a position that is
somewhat comparable to the game but the
big difference is that before five
before has been played and this is
actually a two whites advantage i
believe and we will see in the course of
the game why that is before as this kind
of move is just not a very positive one
for black it didn't help it gives you
this additional idea but the bishop is
not doing much on b5 gimme one was maybe
an idea for white to to improve slightly
on the game yeah 95 black care needs to
take okay SI what we should look at what
about g5 here yeah this is answered by
before now and now this is a bit tricky
if God's now moves the night you get
this problem so g5 wasn't good 95 was
sensible I only think that may be kingly
one was a bit a bit bit harder for black
yeah okay he needs to take on d5
captures and now he played rook to e8 he
is preparing to play play e 6 cm um
black also could have played e6
immediately this wasn't a band move at
all something like that could have
easily happened and it is comparable to
the game but still interesting black has
got some active pieces but white also
has some good centralization especially
the square on deform can be nice for all
pieces e 6 was was possible that he
played the rook e8 one idea is that
after e6 later he wants to take only six
the rook and yeah so it's a sensible way
to play um to pull off no blade rook f1
which is slightly mysterious to me not
one hundred percent sure what the point
of the movers f5 is um I don't they
don't really think that f5 is an idea
what idea could be maybe just to play as
he did in the game with rook afterwards
it's that's possible I still would have
thought that a move like King be one is
much more natural but ok let's look at
let's look at the game look everyone
andy sixx plate yep trying to use the
rukon the evo very am sensible yeah not
a power play droog f 2 i'm looking to
protect c2 and the second-ranked yeah i
did this positional rumba dro firm and
copped a really really funny move yeah
if you look at blacks position you know
what is blacks possible problem peace
well yeah I right probably the night on
a five the night on a five where is it
going it can go to not here not to see
six can go to be seven words doing
nothing and what it is what is it doing
on a five yeah in an idea what you would
sacrifice you at some point but it's not
so easy and apparent how to make that
work yeah mayara first solve the problem
of the night simply by sacrificing it
played night c4 here very a very funny
move and yeah okay the easiest thing for
what is the next move you absolutely
must take it of course you try to not
take it you get here meant checkmate
yeah then after that you can enjoy some
of the Siberian scenery but have stall
have lost very quickly yeah weiter must
take this a night oops here I must take
the night of course
in Rome adyar of just recaptured with
the palm so yes sacrifice the whole
piece and yeah what is the compensation
yeah black has a very substantial thread
of course and this is this basically is
the compensation this is one enormous
threat and this is of course III cutting
yeah somewhat replacing this poem on c3
and then you just need to get the Queen
to be too when it's checkmate and this
is really a big big threat um white only
has a very little playable museum to
defend if you go see three just stopping
this in its tracks you quickly regret
that as after route be eight black a
threatening Queen a five and twenty nine
three and it turns out that despite
white being yeah it's White's moves it
is white smooth and slowly has no way to
prevent that like it's flat-out winning
here those pieces are so our clumsily
placed you have no way to to save
yourself let's say something like that
this also this move coming yeah and this
will be a devastating attack terrible
t1d to c3 is immediately losing what
should why do actually first I thought
maybe this could be an idea trying to
protect those key squares but look at
this route p8 and where's your queen
going now yeah if you go here I can just
win the question this position is
actually not one hundred percent clears
why it's got quite a number of pieces
but it's certainly nothing that why
should aim for I'm in this the only
player can win this is black and you
don't really want to test all this it
turns out that the best movies
to borrow actually played you played the
bishop deform very young yeah wise
decision also to get rid of this this
bishops um or at least them intending to
do that every new blackest of course
doing something something else yeah
black what thoughts should like to know
he really needs to play c3 now the only
logical follow-up to all that and this
in fact leads to 22 exchanges lots of
exchanges white needs to take c3 of
course if you move the Queen that's
again between 8-5 Queen a three and
you're toast so you must take it and he
decided to take with the Queen um Bishop
takes was possible i think but this
allows the additional idea of playing
Quincy five yeah with f2 surprisingly
also hanging and I'm not sure that you
really want to try this as wide what you
did is just the safer choice took with
the Queen and after Queen takes Knight
takes bishop takes root takes rook takes
we have exchanged the whole the whole
see file and got to an end game let's
check whether any alternatives black
took yeah can you do something else so
what can take here but if you consider
this position it's quite comparable to
the game only with the rukon d4 yeah so
I think this was simply best play in for
for both sides yeah white now took only
six to get to the d6 bonus makes lots of
sense rook takes and now look ft to
plate yeah maybe here why turn had a
slight chance to slightly
slightly present this game and continued
by playing and something that can be to
first attacking the rook the idea is
that after g3 you might have Bishop to
d5 and claim that this Bishop is doing
something good for you this is certainly
true by term has this active bishop but
if it's really enough to to do anything
substantial I doubt that but this is
maybe what white could have done to
continue he played look to d2 and this
now after Luke g3 leads to two further
exchanges this is an important desperado
move of course to get your phone back he
had actually got into the rook and
gaming and while porn count it's equal
Freudians form and black will quickly
get in move like f6 such as plate when
it's king will get activated yeah after
this and drew gave five they greet to
draw get their various ways now to
continue most of them check lead to a
complaint exchange here and of course
this is a dead position even if you
would take away upon from whence idea it
would be very much an uneventful draw so
on yeah not a very exciting game at the
end but a very correct game by both
players i believe if you like i did use
an engine to reduce to do to do checks
it's it's really like they didn't do
anything wrong both sides just played
good moves and it ended it ended in a
draw nothing to be on to get to be
disappointed about like a
thirtysomething move drawing an endgame
it's not too exciting but it was really
a good game what
what can you do um yeah maybe this
dragon set up against the h3 isn't too
bad if we consider that I mean whites
moves really makes lots of sense maybe
here this here this king be one so it's
a slight improvement but um in general
blacks position looks are perfectly
perfectly okay yeah for both players to
draw didn't really do anything certainly
um if they hoped for any chance and a
win in this game would be a necessary or
would have been necessary but yeah it's
um it sometimes does not materialize if
both players play well and don't commit
any substantial mistake and draws some
fair result yeah I hope you enjoyed this
game thanks for watching